how's it going bros my name is Fiona bad
welcome to mystery shop to buy flames 3
I play the first mystery I was really
good like really entertaining me this
guy always makes fun and entertaining
maps and we already got language I'm
happy about that I'm really happy
look at my arm when I do this what what
Hey all right all right all right Daniel
has some eggs I don't know I don't even
know I guess we can't go here let's try
this I shall buy eight shells get the
head okay let's see what we already
there we go
bucket of water perfect ice cube are
gonna war on door of fire that make
sense that's the sound I expect when I
make a flame nut go I don't trust
corners alright see what we got here
what is this on Sheth bricks literally I
can't be good
all rights go here what the heck is up
with this room what I'm just oh really
oh just yet off I don't just yeah what
the heck what am I supposed to do it I
can't go anyway ah [ __ ] trust you uh-uh
this is a [ __ ] I knew ah machine room
key
but the [ __ ] all right I thought yeah I
can now adjust status ever hates statues
what is this
barrels get out of here else rare why is
this so much light man and man madam um
alright this through this like it house
entertaining oh all this kind of good
stuff makes me happy
why do you think my name is shir I don't
know I like it I'm happy for you pity
I'm rally and rail go ahead but those
barrels pity I don't like us i I there
shady types she better watch hat I know
barrels okay what's going on here mister
shares tell me what is that what are
they doing yeah okay let's go here
really is that a matter
huh okay let's venture farther and what
the [ __ ] man better yet no I
Oh hater I should have expected that
actually known I played so many signs
why did I know don't jump down Danielle
disappointment let's go up this ladder
yes
oh okay there we go
stupid ladder oh man let's go to map
number two
I thought I was all right let's go here
whoa oh okay
pretty good why no we're good I thought
it was good Oh at the [ __ ] why did he
kill me don't look back just run keep
running and never but I like looking
back we're not okay fine I'll keep
running
please don't appear again okay just keep
running keep running
don't look back what the [ __ ] are you
kidding me huh okay I guess I got like
I'm not gonna go there don't like bag
just run keep running never look back
never I think oh [ __ ]
okay let's go this way now I don't know
what am I supposed to go there just like
I hate this ah hello
okay forget again but this is here
it's confusing it shouldn't be like that
here no nothing yeah I guess I'll stock
them
hmm I don't know
Oh what is this holy [ __ ] machine do I
have the key
no it's just these are [ __ ] I hate
these you have to do the weirdest move
to open them there we go
all right we're good [ __ ] good guys
let's go here hello now anyone mr. share
what are you doing hop in yeah hi your
name I have a patent for a pity can you
solve it or not all right let's see what
this is about
we install lever so that you keep this
place secure the third level has to be
up the fifth level has to be down first
I've it up for security security that's
all I can write down so one and three up
and five down okay I guess this is one
no up up you go by up you go by and you
go to I am body alright that's good oh
wait what was that
I saw the cheating waiting yeah I give
up up down up down down up down up down
down up down up down down yeah we go i
solve the puzzle holy [ __ ]
wait
oh really huh okay that was weird
thank you Bob
I'm down I'm down there okay period on
the walls a lot of period here that's
not good why do I have this key I don't
even know okay
hello yes there we go haunted mattress
no let's get that got here
nope nope
hello okay we're good huh we got a key
pick that pick that bookie
Oh what the [ __ ] they linking guys
now all that matters now okay that's a
[ __ ] man
I think it's twisted nipples this right
that's what you get okay that's very
interesting not a mountain mattress
though sup for this place now the
laundromat okay
why did we came from here right what am
I supposed to go back no I can't go by
Oh anyway oh oh look
I hate cows I hate iron maidens that
just opened myself did you do that miss
kau kau don't look at me like that cow
did you open that cow cow cow Helmut
move
No what you do say don't move against me
oh you [ __ ] cow oh [ __ ] man
all right sure nothing Bad's gonna
happen here all right John I'm just
kidding go bit closer let the [ __ ] mr.
cow cow no cow it's not game cow it's
loading wait too long maybe Oh cow oh
and we're at all cow I'm so disappointed
count this
we're locked in really I like what I
found
secrets I like secrets I've done
mattress huh huh no I was going on it's
lagging so much like so much like
[Music]
Oh God